So as a recap for the
last couple lectures,
we've talked a lot about value
functions and Q-functions.
We'll talk about
them more today.
And as a reminder, value
functions and Q-functions
are representing some
future expected rewards,
starting at some state.
And value function will
be future expected rewards
we start at state and
follow with policy.
And a Q-function is if we start
at a state, take an action,
and then follow it.
And so you can write
these down mathematically
as expected future rewards.
And we've seen these
diagrams a couple of times
where you can think about value
as the sum of future rewards,
but think of Q-functions as
policy rewards plus state.
All right.
We've talked about a
couple methods so far.
The first method
that we talked about
was policy gradients, where we
alternate between collecting
data and improving our policy.
And we can think of it as trying
to get samples for our policy
and increasing the log
likelihood of actions that
have a higher reward in the
future, where we subtract
the baseline in order to
encourage the policy to be more
above average things than
it did before, and less as
of the below average stuff.
We then started to talk
about actor-critic methods.
And in this part, we
introduced an additional step
of this loop, where we are first
going to estimate the expected
future reward for our policy and
use that to improve the policy.
So we had this revised
form for our gradients,
for our policy, where we
are still taking samples,
but increasing the likelihood on
actions that we think are good,
and decreasing the likelihood on
actions that we think are bad.
So these are the methods that
we've talked about so far.
We, last lecture,
focused a lot on how
to do this actor-critic
algorithm in an off-policy way.
So instead of only using the
data from the current iteration,
trying to be able to use all
of the past data from all past
iterations.
And do that, we needed to be
able to estimate a Q-function
from past policy data.
And to do that, we can
use a neural network.
Half of them put a state in
action and output the value.
And we derive this
equation that's
defining the
Q-function recursively.
Or we can think of the
sum of future rewards
as the reward at
the first timestep,
plus the Q-function starting
at the next state and action.
We found that this equation
holds for any state and action,
and that means that we can use
previous state-action and next
state pairs in order to
try to learn a Q-function.
And specifically the way
that we did that is we
would sample a
state-action next state
from our buffer
of previous data.
Then we'll sample a next
action from the current policy,
rather than from
the past policy.
And then we will try to
do supervised learning
on these targets,
where the targets are
using our current estimate of
the Q-function for our policy.
And we pass these inputs
to state, the action,
the next state and
the next action
that the sample [INAUDIBLE].
And so once we formulate this
objective using those two step
Q-values, then we
can use supervised
learning to help with that to
try to match the Q function.
Then we also talked about
for these yi's be accurate,
you need to have sufficient
coverage in your data set
to cover actions that your
newest policy [INAUDIBLE].
So today, we're going to be
covering value-based RL methods.
And specifically,
we'll be talking
about what I think
arguably was the very
first deep reinforcement
learning method,
and it was based on
Q-learning algorithm.
And we'll be talking
about Q-learning,
and then we'll also
be talking about how
to implement Q-learning in
practice, how to make it stable.
And the goal for today is to
think about how Q-functions
relate to policies, how
to do RL without learning
an explicit policy, and
how to stabilize Q-learning
if you're actually [INAUDIBLE].
Cool.
So we're going to start
out with a thought
exercise, and a question for
all of you to think about.
So say we have some policy,
and for your policy,
you have a pretty good
estimate of the Q-function.
And as a reminder, I'll put
the definition of Q-values
up here, where it says future
rewards for a state and action.
And an object that we're going
to be thinking about a lot today
is if you have some estimate of
the Q-function, in this case,
for a policy, then one thing you
could do is you could try to--
instead of following some policy
that you've already learned,
you could potentially
formulate a policy
by choosing the action that
maximizes this Q-value.
So if you have a bunch of
different states and actions,
at a given state, instead
of following your policy,
you could pick the
candidate action
that has the highest Q-value.
So to continue on
this thought exercise,
we'll define a policy
that does exactly that.
That policy has a
probability of 1
for taking the action that
maximizes the Q-value,
and has a probability
of 0 otherwise.
There's just a
deterministic policy
that always follows
what the Q-value is
telling you is the best.
And then we'll look at this
in the context of an example.
So say that we have some
2D navigation problem.
We're going to be starting
somewhere in this blue box,
and our goal is to
get to the star.
We can move in 2D.
The reward is 1 at the star,
and 0 elsewhere, so very simple.
And let's say that our current
policy always goes to the right.
And as one additional
point of detail,
if you're going to move
up, it takes 1 timestep
to move about this distance,
and it takes about 2 timesteps
to move this distance.
So my question for you is, if
you define this new policy--
you have this current policy
that always goes right.
You have an accurate estimate
of the Q-value for that policy.
If you define this
new policy, is that
better than the current policy?
Is worse than the
current policy?
Is it the same as
the current policy?
Is it the optimal policy,
and why or why not?
So I'll give you--
well, first, any questions
about this example?
OK.
I'll give you a
few minutes to talk
to your neighbor
about these questions,
and then we'll come back and
talk through the answers.
It seems like people are
talking a little bit less,
so maybe we can come back.
Who wants to share
their thoughts?
Yeah?
So let's summarize
that, and then
we'll talk about whether
it's the optimal policy.
So summarize the old
policy is going right.
And so that is not optimal
because if you're starting here,
then you're not actually
going to hit the star.
And if you think about what
Q pi is for the old policy,
everything in this
region right here
is going to have
a Q pi equal to 1
for all of these
states and actions.
Also, the-- yeah.
And then if you start
to think about what
Q pi looks like right here,
this is actually where it will--
well, actually, sorry.
Take that back.
V pi is equal to 1 for
everything in this row.
It actually depends a little
bit on the action what
the Q-function actually is.
For this row, if the action
is the same as the policy,
it's going to move right.
Then if Q-value is 1--
if it actually does something
else-- if it goes up,
for example--
then it might
actually miss the star
if it follows the policy
after taking that action.
Now if you look at
this row, for this row,
Q pi of all the states in this
row for the action of going
right is going to be 0.
But then if you look at
the Q pi for all the states
here for the action of going up,
what is the Q value for that?
For Q pi?
1.
Cool.
And so that's because if we
follow up and then follow
the policy, we'll
have a reward of 1.
And then lastly, if we go
to this row, if we have s
and then going up,
what is the key value?
0.
Cool.
And so what this
means is that we're
going to get the new policy.
What it's going to do is it's
going to be going right here.
And then for
everything in this row,
it will be going up
because it's going
to be choosing the action that
has the maximum value of Q pi.
But then for this row,
all of the Q values
are 0 because all of the
Q values for the next one
are also 0.
And so if you default to
the previous behavior,
it'll stay going to the right.
Does anyone want to discuss
the second question?
Is this the optimal policy?
Yeah, so the new policy is
better than the old one,
but it's not the
optimal policy because
in these states, the optimal--
the best policy should be
the one that also is going up
in order to get to the star.
Yeah.
So the question was if we
iterate this and do it a couple
times, this will become
the optimal policy, right?
And yes, you're a
couple slides ahead,
but we'll talk about
doing this iteratively.
Yeah, so we can
get a reward of 1.
The question was, why is
this not the optimal policy?
So we'll get a reward of
1 here, which is great.
But if we're starting
at this initial state,
we actually will just
keep on going right.
We won't go up after
defining this new policy.
And so therefore, it's not
going to get a reward of 1
from all states in [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So the question,
is there a sense
of if you're getting
closer to the star,
the Q would be
higher versus not?
I actually didn't
explicitly define this,
but if you have a discount
factor that is below 1,
then it will get higher
as you get closer.
Everything I've shown here
is with a discount factor
of 1 for simplicity.
But if you use a discount
factor of 0.9, for example,
then the Q-value here would be
1, then it would be 0.9 here,
then 0.8 here, 0.7
here, and so forth.
And then it would still
be 0 for this entire row,
just because you're still
somewhat of a [? slope. ?]
The other thing
potentially to note here
is that if your
reward was denser--
the reward function, instead
of being 1 at the star and 0--
or if it was, for example, the
negative distance to the star,
then you would actually--
I won't go through that.
I won't go through
that on the board.
But if you go
through that example,
you'll actually see that
even in a single step,
starting from this
policy, you would actually
get a policy that goes to
the star from all states.
The question is, if I wanted
to get the optimal policy,
I would need to iteratively
do this and reconsider the Q
pi for the latest
policy every time.
So yeah, that's correct.
Yeah.
So in this example--
the question is,
is it always better?
And this example, the
new policy was better
than the current policy.
And this is actually always
going to be the case.
So it's always going
to be at least as
good as the previous policy.
And it's never going to-- well,
assuming that Q pi is accurate,
it's always going to
be at least as good.
It's never going to be worse.
And now, if Q pi is
already the optimal policy,
then it will be the same.
This is starting to think
about, can we actually start
omitting policies?
So Q is the expected reward.
When we do this arg
max, we're going
to be taking the best
action from state
s if we then follow
the policy afterwards.
And this is going to be at
least as good as any action
that the policy
would have taken.
And regardless of what the
policy is, this is going to be,
yeah, at least as good as what
that policy would've been.
We do that because it's
taking the action that has
the maximum expected reward.
So potentially,
we could actually
just forget using
policies and just
do this rather than
actually explicitly learning
a neural network for the policy.
And so what this looks like
as an iterative algorithm is
we would run our
policy to collect data,
then we would fit a
model to estimate Q pi.
According to that
latest plot for data,
you could also do this
in your off-policy way,
like we talked about
in the last lecture.
And then to improve
your policy, you
can just define the policy
to be the policy that
maximizes the Q pi.
And then once you
define that new policy,
you can collect new data and
then estimate again Q- pi.
But in this case, Q
pi for your new policy
and not your old policy.
The policy pi is equal
to this, and so we're not
learning a neural network
for the policy pi.
We're not explicitly
representing it as a model.
But it's helpful to
have some notation
to refer to the [INAUDIBLE].
The only neural network
here, the only model
here is this Q pi [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So the question is, how
do we generalize this
to continuous actions or more
expressive action spaces?
So this is generally
going to be easiest
when you have a discrete set
of actions that you might face,
like going up,
going to the right.
If you have continuous
actions, you actually
can still use this algorithm.
Although, you need to figure
out how to perform that
max operation.
There's a couple ways
that you could conceivably
run this operation right here.
In principle, you
could use something
like gradient descent,
although that turns out
not to work very well.
You can potentially-- there's
a variety reasons why it cannot
work very well.
And if your actions are
not very high dimensional,
then it might actually
be better just
to simply try to sample a
bunch of different actions
and pick the one that
has the highest Q value.
You can also-- there's other
sampling based optimization
algorithms where you can
iteratively sample and refine
your estimates from there.
Yeah, so there's a couple
of things you can do there.
If you have a discrete
action space that's--
like [INAUDIBLE], for example--
in principle, you could do
some sort of discrete search
over things where the Q
value is what you're trying
to maximize in that system.
Yeah, how does
this work in cases
where the rewards
are very sparse?
So we saw one example where
the rewards are sparse,
and it can still work
in this scenario.
The thing that you need to be
aware of when the rewards are
sparse is that you may need
to do this loop of refitting
the policy potentially
a large number of times
because each time you do
this, you're actually-- like,
the first time, we only
got a good policy here.
And now if this environment
was much bigger,
that means that you need to
keep on doing it as you go down.
And what is often
referred to as a backup,
you're backing up the rewards
from here to the other state.
And you'll need to do
those backups for--
essentially, it goes for as long
as the horizon of the problem
is.
You just need to make
sure that you're doing
many iterations [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Cool.
So let's see.
We can write this
down as an algorithm.
And so we can take
our off policy
actor-critic algorithm
that is fitting Q pi.
And then instead of using this
policy gradient update, simply
define a new policy that's
taking actions according to
[INAUDIBLE].
And you can think of this as
really having two key steps
like what we talked about.
One is estimating Q pi.
This is often referred
to as policy evaluation
because you're learning what
the values are for a policy.
And note that you can do
multiple gradient steps here
because this is isn't on policy.
We're just trying
to fit our target.
And then the second step
is improving our policy,
so you refer to it as
policy improvement.
And this two-step
iterative procedure
is often called
policy iteration.
It's on the way to
an algorithm like Q.
Cool.
So on the--
I'll write this
out on the board.
What this looks like
is having a first step
where you collect data.
Oftentimes, you might
collect data from pi.
It might also be-- it
could actually potentially
be from some other policy.
Then you have a next
step where you're
going to try to
fit your estimated
Q-function for that policy.
And you can use the
targets that we defined
in the last lecture of r of
sa plus gamma times Q, where
these are from the buffer and
this is sampled from our policy.
And then lastly, we'll
improve our policy
by defining a new
policy as being 1
if [INAUDIBLE] is maximizing
Q value, and 0 otherwise.
The question is, is this
policy deterministic?
Yes, this policy
is deterministic.
This is actually one
reason why you might not
want to collect data
from this policy
because you're not going
to have that much diversity
in your actions.
And we'll talk, in
a couple slides,
about what policy you might want
to collect data from instead.
Yeah.
So the question is, when
we're fitting these targets,
why are we sampling
from a prime?
And why not do a maximum
over actions or an average?
So there's a couple
of things here.
So first, you can do an average
and sample multiple times.
And that can give you a better
estimate of the target value.
The second thing is that
you can actually-- instead
of sampling this from
pi, you can actually
do this improvement step in
the Q-function target itself.
So you can actually--
instead of defining
yi this way, you
could consider a target
for your Q-function
to be the reward plus
gamma times the max
over a prime of Qs.
And what this looks like
is something like this.
And this actually
is what gets us Q.
And one way to think about
this is-- a couple ways
to think about this.
The first is that these targets
are actually your Q-values
for your new policy.
So you're already putting
the improvement steps
in your Q-function update,
and you're actually
learning the Q-values
associated with the new policy
that you're going
to be defining.
And there's actually another
way to look at this as well.
So we previously
defined this equation
that's true for all
states and actions.
So we defined that
the Q-function
is equal to the reward plus the
Q-function at the next state.
This is true for all
states and actions,
and it's actually also true
for any policy, including
the optimal policy.
And you could
actually write down
another equation
that is specifically
for the optimal policy.
And in particular, we know that
the optimal policy is always
going to be taking
the actions that
maximize our future rewards.
So the optimal policy
is always going to be--
the action that
it picks is always
going to be the one that
maximizes the Q-value.
And so we can write down
an equation that holds just
for the optimal policy which
is the same equation as the one
there, except instead
of an expectation
over the next action,
it's a maximization
over the next action.
So what that looks
like is we're defining
the Q-function as the reward
at the current timestep
plus the sum of future rewards.
And for that sum
of future rewards,
we have some expectation over
the next state that will happen.
And then because we know that
the optimal policy or the best
policy is going to be taking
the action that is maximizing
the Q-value, then we can
write this as the max of Q
at the next state.
Yeah.
So the question is, why
are we talking all about Q,
and why not V?
So you can actually
also write down
these equations for V
in a very similar way.
The thing that's
very nice about Q
is that we can actually
get a policy out of Q.
So if we know what Q is, then we
can do this arg max over actions
to get a policy that's better
than our previous policy.
Whereas with the value function,
if we only know V of s,
then we don't know which action
will lead to higher [INAUDIBLE].
In principle, with
the value function,
you could try to
do some look ahead.
If you have a sense for
what the dynamics are,
you could try to
predict what s prime is,
and pick actions that
are maximizing that.
And so what that
would look like is
trying to pick actions
that lead leads
to an expectation like
a high future value.
So you could, in principle,
do something like this with V.
But we don't know what
these dynamics are,
and we can't
necessarily predict what
the next state will be as a
consequence of our actions.
And so in general,
it's a lot harder
to get a policy out
of a value function
than it is to improve
our policy, ultimately,
with the value function than
it is with a Q function.
So now going back
to this equation,
this is true for
the optimal policy.
And you can write Q
for the optimal policy
here, where I'm writing pi
star as the optimal policy.
And if you look at
our update right here,
we're trying to fit a Q-function
that's predicting this.
And essentially,
with this equation,
you can think about it as
this update is actually trying
to make this equation true.
So we're trying to make the
left side of the equation
equal to the right
side of the equation.
And when this equation is
true that means our policy
is optimal.
So essentially, one way
to think about Q-learning
is that when we're
optimizing step 3,
we're trying to find a
Q-function such that it
satisfies this
equation, which is only
true for the optimal policy.
Yeah, sorry.
This is-- it's an [INAUDIBLE].
So this only holds for
the optimal policy.
And if you have the optimal
policy, then [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, great question.
So the question is if we have
really good estimates of Q,
will this converge?
We'll talk about
this in one minute.
So let's first just talk about
some terminology really quick.
Reinforcement learning
has a ton of terminology.
It's useful to
know some of it so
that if someone's talking to
you about reinforcement learning
or you're reading a paper, you
know what they're talking about.
This first equation
is often referred to
as the Bellman equation.
It's very useful
objects, and it's
what we were using
to try to do policy
evaluation for our policy.
And the second equation is
called the Bellman optimality
equation because it's
specifically for optimal policy.
Sometimes people also informally
might call the second one
Bellman equation as well.
But yeah, officially, the
first one is Bellman equation.
Second one is Bellman
optimality equation.
You can derive
equations like this
that are also for the
value function V instead
of the Q-function,
and people also
refer to those as Bellman
equation and Bellman optimality.
OK.
So getting back to the question,
if we do this iteratively,
will we converge to
the optimal policy?
There's good news
and bad news here.
The good news is that if you're
in a very simple setting where
you can actually store
all of your key values
in a table for every
single state and action,
this would be for a very
small, discrete state
and maximum state.
And if you have
sufficient exploration,
then this algorithm
will converge.
So that's the good news.
The bad news is that basically
in any other scenario,
it is not guaranteed
to converge.
And you can construct
scenarios when
it diverges even
with this linear Q
function, which is kind of sad.
I guess the flip side of
that is that even though it
can diverge in scenarios, it
can be made to work very well.
And we'll see some examples
of it working very well
at the end of lecture.
Yeah, so the question
is, what does this mean?
What does this statement mean?
And it is a bit vague.
So specifically, it
doesn't necessarily
have to do with the
accuracy of your Q values
because you're actually
going to be fitting your Q
values through this process.
It's more a statement of the
size of your state and action
space.
And if it's small enough that
you can maintain this table--
and there's also a
condition on exploration
where you actually need to
have full coverage of the state
and actions in your data set--
then it will convert.
OK.
So M note about this is
Q-learning is off policy.
And in particular,
this equation holds
for all states and actions.
And it means that we don't
have to have the actions coming
from our current policy.
And in particular, it might
actually make a lot of sense
for it to be broader
than our current policy
because we're going to be doing
this maximization over our Q
values.
And so when we do
this maximization,
we're going to be
considering a lot
of different possible actions.
And if we have a
discrete action space,
we might actually just consider
all of the possible actions.
And when we do that, we
would want our Q values
to be accurate when we're
considering all of them.
And if there's one action
that we haven't collected
data for that we're
going to be considering
in this maximization, it
might be erroneously high
because we didn't
collect any data for it.
And then you'll get an
inaccurate target value
when you are fitting your Q.
And so instead of collecting
data from our current policy,
it'd be useful to collect data
from some exploration policy,
and specifically,
a policy that's
collecting a broader
set of actions
than our deterministic policy.
So we want coverage for a
lot of different actions,
specifically for this term.
And there's a couple
of choices here.
One choice is to follow our
policy most of the time,
but with some small probability,
take a completely random action.
And so what that would
look like is a policy
that with some probability--
I would say maybe
you can write it
as take a random action with
probability epsilon and follow--
maybe we can call
this pi exploration--
and follow your current policy
probability 1 minus epsilon.
And you can write that out
slightly more formally up here.
And this can be a
good choice because it
means that when you take an
actual uniform at random,
it means that you'll get very
good coverage of the actions
that you consider.
And oftentimes, as you
proceed through training,
you might start with
a larger epsilon
so that you have
more exploration
at the beginning of training.
And then as your policy
is getting better
and as you're getting a better
estimate of your Q-function,
you can then make them
smaller and explore
less as you go through phase.
So this is called
epsilon-greedy because you're
being greedy some of
the time, and epsilon
probability of the time, you're
not being greedy and just taking
a random [? function. ?]
OK.
And then another
choice that's also
somewhat reasonable, although
a little bit more complicated,
is to take actions
with probability that
is proportional to the Q value.
And so if you have actions
that have a higher Q value,
then take those actions
more frequently.
And if you have actions
with lower probability,
then take those actions
less frequently.
One way to write this is you
could exponentiate your Q values
so that they're all
positive, and then
normalize in order
to get a probability
distribution over [INAUDIBLE].
Sometimes this is called
Boltzmann exploration,
named after the
Boltzmann distribution
where you exponentiate
a [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah.
So the question is, it's
straightforward to do
this with discrete actions.
How do you do these
kinds of approaches
when you have
continuous actions?
The first one is indeed
a lot more common
with discrete actions.
You can still do something like
this with continuous actions,
but you would need to define
some uniform-ish distribution
over your continuous actions.
And for that, you would need
some sort of range or something.
Instead, you could also
use a Gaussian distribution
with a wide standard
deviation, in principle,
where you sample from that.
I think in continuous
action spaces,
this second option
is a bit more common.
In terms of sampling from
it, off the top of my head,
I actually can't
remember the details
of how you would
sample from this,
but we can post on
[? Ed ?] afterwards.
It's possible that the way
that you do it is actually just
to try to fit a
policy, but yeah, we
can talk about it afterwards.
OK, so putting the
pieces together,
what a full Q-learning
algorithm looks like is we'll
collect data using some policy.
We'll add that data
to our replay buffer,
then we will sample
a batch of data
from our replay
buffer uniformly.
And this is useful to
sample about separately
from what we just
collected so that we
are de-correlating and sampling
IID from our replay buffer.
And then we will
update our Q-function
by taking the gradient of the L2
loss with respect to the target.
And so if you write
that out, you'll
get a gradient that
looks like this, where--
yeah, if you're taking the
L2 loss, then on the inside,
this is the inside of L2 loss.
And then you use the chain
rule to get the second term
right here that's
backpropagating
into your parameter.
You can repeat these
multiple times.
So you can actually take
multiple gradient steps
after collecting
a batch of data.
In practice, it's
actually pretty common
to set K equals to 1.
But you're going to be more data
efficient if you have a larger
K, if you take more gradient
steps for a given batch of data.
And then you also
iterate this process.
After you're done
taking gradient steps,
then you can collect some
more data and repeat.
Yeah.
So the question was, if you're
collecting data from any policy,
wouldn't that be less optimal
than using a good policy
or using your current policy?
Yeah.
So the reason why you might
use a different policy is--
the reason why you might
use a different policy
is specifically to learn a
more accurate Q-function,
and so it's actually
going to help you learn
a more optimal policy later.
And essentially,
there's this trade-off
between collecting less
optimal data at the beginning
to help you be better later on.
And one way to think
about this is if you are--
say you're reinforcement
learning agent
is trying to help you
pick a restaurant.
If you haven't really explored
that many restaurants to know
what is a good restaurant,
then at the beginning,
probably you want to explore
and actually try things-- even
restaurants that might
be suboptimal-- in order
to get a good estimate of
what good restaurants are
for a particular person.
And then later on, once
you have a good estimate
for what good
restaurants are, then
you might want to
then explore less.
So visually, what
this looks like is
you have some environment.
You'll initialize your
replay buffer as empty.
And then at this first step,
you'll run your policy--
like the epsilon-greedy policy--
that's exploring
in the environment.
You'll then get some
transitions that you
put into your replay buffer.
And then for this part, you'll
then use your replay buffer
to update your Q-function
on the data that you see,
with the goal of
trying to get something
that is not saying the
Q-function of the [? optimal. ?]
So the question is, when
we combine this with 1,
can we still call
this off policy?
Because we are collecting
data potentially from a policy
that's very similar
to our current policy.
Because we're using a
replay buffer of essentially
all of our past experience,
when we do these updates,
it's referred to as off policy.
That doesn't mean
that none of the data
is from our current policies.
So some of the data
in the replay buffer
will be from the current policy.
But essentially,
what off policy means
is that you are not
only using that data,
you're also using data
from other policies.
In practice, what
is the some policy?
Yeah.
So in practice, it's
exactly what we talked about
on the last slide.
So it would either be
something like epsilon-greedy,
where with some
small probability,
you're taking a random action
and otherwise following
the policy.
Or it's something where you're
taking actions in proportion
to the [INAUDIBLE].
And it might actually,
as you talked about it,
might actually change
during training.
You might actually
change epsilon
during training so
that you're doing
more exploration at the
beginning, and less exploration
later on.
Yeah.
So the question is,
are we resetting
our learning of each iteration?
Oftentimes, you'll keep your
old Q parameters around,
warm start them, and keep
on training on top of them.
One important thing-- so the
results of this algorithm is Q.
And then to extract
a policy out of that,
the final policy that you would
then deploy is a policy that is
acting according to--
essentially, just
be acting greedily,
where it's taking the
actions that maximize your Q.
Oh, so if the size of the replay
buffer is 1, then just-- like,
yeah, 1 data point--
then that would be on policy.
So if it's tiny, then
that's fully on policy.
In practice, this replay
buffer is a lot larger.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry.
Right.
If the replay buffer size is 1,
if this policy is not the same
as this, then that's
still off policy
because the policy is different.
Yeah, so good point.
So yeah, this policy might
be different from the one
that directly [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, so how do we
manage our replay buffer?
Make sure that we're
not oversampling states,
and so forth?
This is generally--
it's actually
an important consideration
with Q-learning algorithms.
And usually, you will
discard old data.
So you'll have a first
in, first out principle
where this buffer is
not infinitely large.
Oftentimes, with Q-learning,
it is pretty large.
But you can just
pick a fixed size.
And then once you have
filled it to that size,
start discarding data and
discard the oldest data first.
One other consideration is
that at the very beginning
of training, the replay
buffer might be very small.
Sometimes to handle
that, you might
try to collect more data in
the very first iteration just
to populate it.
There are also algorithms
that we won't quite
cover that do asynchronous
data collection and updates
because data
collection takes time.
Updating a neural
network takes time.
And so you could actually have
some threads that are actually
adding to the replay buffer, and
other threads that are running
updates on your queue function.
With those asynchronous
algorithms,
it's actually especially
important to think about how
the replay buffer is managed so
that you're not running 1,000
gradient steps on
one data point,
and 1 gradient step on another.
Cool.
That's Q-learning.
Let's talk a little bit about
what happens in practice when
you use these methods.
So we talked about how
Q-learning can diverge.
And in general, when you run
Q-learning with neural networks,
it can be unstable.
And one of the reasons for that
is you have this moving target.
This max is [INAUDIBLE].
And it means that our
optimization process
is very non-stationary,
especially as K is 1.
And one trick is
to try to slow down
how often we change the target.
The target network.
So instead of having the
target change every single time
you change your
parameters, one idea
is you could freeze the
parameters of your target
network and only update
them periodically.
Only update them once
every 100 gradient steps,
or something like that.
So what this looks
like is we can
save a separate neural
network, another copy
of our Q-function parameters.
We'll call this phi prime.
And when we say this out, then
just for this target right here,
we can use these new parameters
Q phi prime in our target.
These parameters will
be frozen, and so it
means that inside
this inner loop,
the labels will not change.
And so this inner
loop is essentially
going to be doing supervised
learning with some data being
added to the replay buffer.
So this would be
a lot more stable.
Supervised learning is a
lot more stable, generally.
And then only periodically,
then update our target network
parameters be the same as
our latest Q-function script.
So once we use the
target network,
this is referred to
as the DQN algorithm.
It was introduced in 2013.
It was basically like the
first deep RL method, at least
in my opinion.
And they found that
you could actually
train neural networks to play
a variety of different Atari
games.
And it was one of the first
examples of using reinforcement
learning to train
neural networks to do
a pretty complicated task.
And they were actually
training it directly
from the pixel
observations from the game.
And prior to that, a lot of
reinforcement learning examples
were on varied [? toy ?]
settings or very low
dimensional settings,
or something like that.
If you take two
tables of Q-values,
will that be the
same [INAUDIBLE]?
Yeah, so that's actually
not quite the case
because you will
actually be collecting
new data in this loop.
And so you can't just
store all the Q-values.
You actually do have
to store the parameters
so that you can then compute
the Q-values for the new data.
The target Q-values.
And then [INAUDIBLE].
So you can't just store
these, the Q-values.
You have to [INAUDIBLE] them.
Cool.
And so this is one
of the algorithms
that you'll implement
in homework 2.
OK, so that's the first trick
is use a target network that you
only periodically update.
There's two more
things that make
Q-learning work a lot better.
And the first one is actually
looking at the accuracy
of the Q-values.
So if you plot the reward over
training, the reward goes up,
so that's good.
This is a reward on
the game of Breakout
and the game of Seaquest.
And if you also
plot the Q-values
over the course of training,
they're also going up.
And so that's typically
what you expect
because the Q-values
is representing
your average reward,
so that's good.
One other thing to note
actually is a practical tip.
When you're looking at the
loss function on your Q values
during training, when
you train with DQN,
the loss values will actually
often go up through training.
This is sometimes a
little bit alarming
because you're used to
loss values going down.
But the reason for that is
you're collecting new data
and that new data
has higher Q-values,
and so the scale of
your loss function
is decreasing
throughout training.
And at the very beginning,
if you're getting zero reward
everywhere, it might be
very easy to get a loss
function that's going up.
So yeah, don't be alarmed if
your loss function is going up.
Sometimes that means
that the policy
is starting to [INAUDIBLE].
So, cool.
This looks pretty good.
As we predicted, Q increases.
So does the return.
You can also look at
the value over training.
And you see that
in the first case,
the values right here
are fairly uniform.
But once you're in a state
where you really have to go up,
then the Q-value for the action
of up is higher than going down
or a no-op.
Likewise, right here, it's
really important to go up.
And so the Q-value is
higher for going up
than the actions of
going down are no-op.
In the right case,
it doesn't really
matter because the ball is on
the other side on the opponent's
side, and so the Q-values
are more uniform.
So when you visualize
these Q-values,
they look pretty
reasonable, which is good.
But then if you actually plot
like what the true returns are--
the true returns
are shown in red
here on this red
horizontal line,
and the estimate of the values
according to the Q-network
are shown as this upper line.
And you actually see
this really huge gap
between the estimate, where the
estimate is always a lot higher
than the true value.
And so it seems
like we're seeing
a lot of what's
called overestimation,
where our Q-function
is overestimating
how good our policy is.
And then there's this
algorithm that I've
introduced called
double DQN that's
able to get a much more
accurate Q-function,
and it's able to overestimate
far, far less than DQN.
So let's talk a little
bit about double DQN,
and overestimation in general.
So our target value is--
let's see.
We're taking a max
over action right here.
And when we take this max,
we're choosing an action
that maximizes its Q-value.
And another way to write this
is you can think of it as--
I might need a little bit.
You can think about this
quantity as Q of phi of s
evaluated at the action that
is maximizing our Q phi.
And so we're both using an
action that has a high Q-value,
and evaluating the Q-value
of that action using
the same Q-function.
And this means that if there
is noise in our Q-function,
then it's very easy.
This noise is very
easy to basically pick
actions that are using that
noise to get a higher Q-value.
And so this last
term right here is
what's causing overestimation.
It's not perfect.
It has some noise in it, as
neural networks generally do.
And because the action
selected according to Q
is the same as what's
being evaluated,
then you can really
exploit that noise
and use actions that
have higher value
than they actually do
because of the noise.
Now, if you instead use
a different Q-function
for picking an action
and evaluating it,
then you can
de-correlate the noise
because if you had two
different Q-functions,
they would have,
naturally, different noise
and different
errors [INAUDIBLE].
And so if you have a way
to use different Q-values,
we can actually then eliminate
this problem of overestimation
by essentially
de-correlating the noise
by using a different Q-function
to estimate the Q actions here
as to evaluate the [? action. ?]
And so the key idea
behind double Q-learning
is to use two different
networks-- one network,
network a, for picking
the action, and network b
for evaluating.
And then if they're
noisy in different ways,
then we're not going
to then be exploiting
noise in our Q-values.
And then, as a result, not
overestimating our Q-values.
The question is, can
you guarantee that they
don't have the same noise?
I guess you definitely
can't guarantee it,
and there might be
some noise that's
a result of the
architecture of the network.
But in practice, this
ends up making a really--
if you are using different
neural networks for this,
it generally does
a very good job.
There's still some
overestimation.
And if we looked
at these values--
like here, in this
game, the Q-values
are still an overestimate,
still an overestimate here,
and also here as well.
But it helps substantially
compared to not doing it.
So it's not perfect, but
it helps quite a bit.
The question is, what if you
did triple DQN or quadruple
DQN, used even more networks?
So good question.
I could see that, yeah, perhaps
if the noise correlation--
if you're able to get even
more samples of noise,
that could help.
It could be interesting
to try that in practice.
If the noise is coming from--
if it's instead coming from a
source that's kept constant,
like the architecture of the
neural network or something
like that, then it
might not help until you
start to introduce those.
And then in practice, using
more than two neural networks
is very impressive.
How do you ensure that
they don't diverge?
So let's actually talk
about what we actually do.
So we're actually already
using two neural networks.
We have the current neural
networks and the target neural
network that was
periodically frozen.
And so what we can actually do
is when we do our Q updates,
we can use the target network--
Q phi prime-- for evaluating,
and the current neural network
for [INAUDIBLE].
And-- yeah.
So that's essentially what
double Q-learning looks like,
where instead of using the
target network for both
of these, we're going to use
the current network to take
the action to pick the best
action, and then the target
network [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, so it's always going
to be your previous Q,
and so you can't
[INAUDIBLE] yeah.
Yeah.
So the question
is, why does this
help, especially if the
previous Q is the same noise?
So the previous Q
will be outdated,
and the new Q will have gotten
a lot of gradient updates
since then, and seen new
data points recently.
And so oftentimes,
the noise isn't just
about the initialization,
But it also
has to do with what
updates were applied.
And so yeah, it helps a lot.
OK.
The last trick
we'll talk about--
which we've already talked
about in actor-critic methods--
is n-step returns.
So our Q-learning
target looks like this--
the reward plus the max of
Q. If your Q-values are good,
then this term is actually going
to be really, really important
in playing most of the
roles in Q-learning update.
But if your Q-function is
bad, like at the beginning
of training, then
these are really
the only values that
are going to matter,
and these are the
values that are
going to be giving your
learning algorithms [INAUDIBLE].
And if you just have a single
reward function here, then
that might be a bit troublesome
because just a single reward
function might not
tell you that much
about how good your Q-value is.
So if you remember
when we talked
about actor-critic
methods, we talked
about using n-step returns.
So if we use this Monte Carlo,
we would use the sum of rewards.
If we use bootstrapping,
we just do r plus V--
so r, the current timestep,
plus the V at the next timestep.
And instead, we talked
about this thing
that we could do in
the middle, where
we sum the rewards over
the next n timesteps,
and then use the value at
the timestep after that.
We talked about how this has
less variance and lower bias,
and lower bias in the sense
that if your targets are bad,
the reward function is
going to be more accurate.
So can we do this for Q-values?
And what this would look
like for Q-values is instead
of having something like this,
I say, this is the target for--
you're trying to get
the target for st, at.
Then you would define yi to
be r at the current timestep
plus r at the next
timestep, up until r
at e plus n minus 1 timestep.
And then at the timestep after
that, use the max of Q of st
plus n, at plus n, where this
maximization is over at plus n.
This is what n-step returns
could look like for Q-learning.
Does anyone see any potential
issue with using this target?
Yeah.
So if you're doing
this off policy,
these r's will be coming
from whatever policy
you used in the replay buffer,
rather than the optimal policy,
which is what you're
trying to estimate
the Q-function for that.
So there's pros and cons here.
One is that it's a lot
less biased, a lot faster
to learn on,
especially early on.
But the downside is
that these rewards
are for the policy that
collected the data, not
for the optimal policy.
And we're trying to
estimate the Q-function
for the optimal policy.
So this is a downside when using
n-step returns with Q-learning.
And this is not an
issue with n equals 1
because there, the reward will
just be a function of s and a,
and we're estimated
the Q-value of s and a.
Now, what do we do about this?
Maybe the unsatisfying answer
is that most commonly, just
ignore this.
Pretend it isn't true, and
still use an n greater than 1.
And n-step returns
truly are often--
truly very often improve the
performance of the algorithm,
despite being incorrect.
That said, there are
other things you can do.
You can dynamically
choose n, and only
use data that follows
the current policy.
Basically looking at
what actions were taken
and seeing if those
actions actually agree
with the maximal Q-values.
You could also, in principle,
dynamically choose n
and have n be smaller
later in training,
where your Q-values are
likely to be more accurate.
Now, for this particular
choosing of n,
you really would
want to do this only
if the action space is small and
the data is mostly on policy.
And you can also do
importance sampling as well
and weight these
rewards by [INAUDIBLE].
Great.
So those were the three tricks
for Q-learning in practice.
There's a couple
examples of Q-learning
that have been very successful
that I put on this slide.
I think there's
other examples too.
But one of the most prominent
examples was for playing games.
And if you want to train
an agent to play a game,
or either just for the sake
of seeing how well you can do
or to play against
the human, Q-learning
was able to outperform
most people on Atari games.
So this bar right here is--
everything above this
bar are the games
that it is at human level or
above human level performance.
And everything below is worse
than human level performance.
And then it also was used to
train a robot grasping system.
So this is actually a
case of continuous action.
And the robot on the right
is using a Q-function that
was trained with Q-learning.
And then it is doing a
continuous optimization
over actions that
will try to find
a good way to grasp the object.
And we talked a bit last
time about how with RL, you
can get much higher success
rate and more reliable policies.
And we see that here
too, where this system
was able to get a 96% success
rate, so quite high at being
able to grasp objects.
The other thing that's
nice about using
RL for this application
is in order to grasp,
you need to not just go
down and pick something up,
but you actually need to
move around the object.
It's also able to
learn how to do
that using the reinforcement
learning because it's
treating it as [INAUDIBLE].
Cool.
I think that one of the last
things I figured I would cover
is some of my advice on
when to use one online RL
algorithm versus another, since
this is the last online RL
method that we'll talk about.
So we talked a bit
about PPO, SAC, and DQN.
Those are some of the three
main technical algorithms
we talked about.
So PPO, this is great when
you care about stability
and ease-of-use.
Generally, doesn't
require too much tuning,
but it's very data inefficient.
And so it's great to use when
you care about stability,
ease-of-use, and
you don't really
care about data efficiency.
DQN works quite
well when you have
discrete actions or low
dimensional continuous actions.
And so in those cases,
it can be a great choice.
It can be fairly data efficient,
depending on some of the details
and how off policy you make it.
And then soft actor-critic
and variants of it
are great when you care
most about data efficiency,
but require a bit more tuning
and are a bit less stable
than something like DQN.
So what we talked about is
Q-learning, also Q-learning
in practice with respect
to target networks,
double DQN, and n-step returns.
We define things like
the Bellman equation
and Bellman optimality equation.
Yeah, and that was
essentially an overview
of how to do RL without
learning an explicit policy.
We're done with online
reinforcement learning
algorithms for now.
And yeah, we covered
a lot of the basics
of different online
reinforcement learning
algorithms.